i'm joined by the shadow foreign
secretary lisa nandy um
lisa nandy i i want to talk about the uh
omicron variant first um the prime
minister's in reintroduced quarantine
measures we've now got contact tracing
again stricter rules on face masks
i'm guessing you support those measures
are they enough
yeah i want to thank the scientists who
spotted the danger with this new omicron
variant very quickly and the government
of course has announced a new package of
measures which we'll consider in
parliament on monday but when the prime
minister comes to parliament on monday
there are a number of outstanding holes
in our defenses that he's got to address
there still seems to have been very
little action on ventilation in public
buildings especially schools which is
going to cause major problems if we
think
the virus the new variant is as
transmissible as scientists are
suggesting there are still some
outstanding issues around travel the
government is saying everyone has to
have a pcr test on day two when they
arrive back in the uk but they're not
suggesting pre-departure tests for
people before they board flights there's
no advice for people about traveling
back from the airport on public
transport and there are very few checks
on the pcr tests that are done so these
are all things that for months the
government has been warned about and
when he comes to parliament on monday
these are things that he's going to have
to be able to answer
so these are generally speaking though
um issues of detail aren't they but you
aren't pressing for a return to working
from home uh or mandatory masks in
hospitality venues and so on
we've always said that math squaring in
crowded spaces and flexible working from
home where people can ought to be part
of plan a we've been watching covid
rates rise across the country for
several months now and we've been urging
the government to do this much more
quickly
we've always said as well that the
government ought to be guided by the
science and it would be one of the
questions we'll be asking on monday of
the prime minister is what are the
scientists advising about mask wearing
is this a political decision to try to
limit mass squaring only to public
transport and shops or are there good
reasons why we ought to consider
extending that in the end this is about
preventing the virus from getting out of
control more people dying the nhs being
overwhelmed and another lockdown taking
place and we've been keen to avoid that
since day one and that's why we want the
government to come to parliament on
monday and be able to answer those what
i think are fairly reasonable questions
it to me as though to some extent you
accept uh what lies behind uh what the
health secretary just been saying to me
which is that there's a kind of balance
to be struck between
um responding to new variants and making
sure we don't shut down uh life as it's
currently being um carried on
businesses and so on and so forth um in
essence
you're accepting the strategy that mr
johnson laid out yesterday
so there is a balance to be struck i
think the health secretary is right
about that we don't think the government
has been getting the balance right up to
now and that's why we support the
measures to bring in
greater use of masks mandatory masks in
some settings and we'll be asking
questions about whether the scientific
basis for that suggests that that needs
to go further we desperately want to see
them title up the travel restrictions
there's a real problem when for 18
months the government has been warned
that there are holes in those defenses
and still hasn't taken action to plug
what you rightly suggested are just
practical measures that could be dealt
with in order to stop the va the new
variant spreading around the country if
we have one big criticism of the
government's approach it's actually
about why these new variants are
emerging
we haven't met our promises that we made
this summer at the g7 to get the vaccine
rolled out to other parts of the globe
there is now sufficient vaccine in order
to ensure that it reaches almost every
adult in the world the problem is that
there is no global plan to get the
vaccine to people in places like south
africa and many of the surrounding
countries that have even worse rates of
vaccination and as the medical chief
medical officer has said to us many many
times when you have huge numbers and
rising numbers of cases of covid that's
when you're like more likely to see new
variants
emerging the government has been warned
about this the prime minister said that
we were leading the world on this on
saturday it is simply not true we're
lagging behind the european union we're
nowhere near
coming close to meeting the commitments
that he made this summer and until and
unless we start to show some global
leadership around this we're going to
keep seeing this reappearing
but this is a global issue isn't it i
mean the south south africans have been
saying in the last 48 hours that
uh the
number of vaccinations that are sitting
in the vaults i mean their numbers
between 100 million and 500 million
being quoted unused
is a scandal for the whole of europe and
north america it's not just a british
problem is it
well it's it's a british problem because
you can see
that we're now dealing with the omicron
variant on our shores
and it's having major implications for
the way that people live as well as for
the national health service so of course
you're right that it's a problem that
requires global cooperation but it
requires britain to do our part and
currently the uk is not delivering on
the promises that we made we said we'd
get 100 million vaccines out to the rest
of the world and then instead of doing
that we've delivered about 10
of that commitment and we've also
slashed aid to many of the countries
that need investment in their health
care systems in order to get the jabs
into people's arms the prime minister
knows this he knows that this is the
reason this lack of global leadership is
the reason why we're seeing new variants
emerge and so while we're keen to
support
measures to protect the british public
and protect the nhs you really have to
ask why the government hasn't got its
act together in order to tackle the
problem at source when in june the prime
minister was keen to wave a british flag
and say that that's precisely what he
was doing
there's been anger in southern africa at
the
block the stopping of flight
would you
have supported that had you been asked
i i think it's absolutely the right
thing to do to suspend flights from not
just south africa but surrounding
countries and i appreciate that that is
a very difficult thing when it happens
to countries i mean certainly you know i
had many constituents making
representations to me
when we had travel bans in place for
britain
for quite a long time britain's couldn't
fly to the united states for example
because of the high rates here and it is
a very difficult thing to accept but the
first duty of any government is to keep
its citizens safe i think these measures
are
sensible and
one of the questions that we've asked
the health secretary to address is
whether there are other countries that
ought to be added to that list countries
in the area in the region with
high rates of infection
and whether
the government is going to come forward
with ways to check on the pcr tests that
are being done when people return to the
uk we can't afford to keep making the
same mistakes that we've made for 18
months over and over again and leave
these big holes in our defenses at a
time when we're struggling to get on top
of an existing or new variant
let's turn to what also appears to be a
perennial
problem to which we haven't found a
solution that is the channel crossings
with the deaths this week um
everyone including you says that french
and british need to sit down work
together that's a given
but um
why hasn't that happened do you think
who's to blame here is it boris johnson
for being
overly provocative or is it emmanuel
macron for overreacting
well france blames britain britain
blames france the truth is that both
governments are engaging in a blame game
while children drown off our coastline
it's just simply unconscionable and any
responsible government on either side of
the channel would set aside those
differences and work together to deal
with what is a collective shared problem
that will only be solved together it's
not just that they failed to agree the
very pressing and urgent need to disrupt
the people smugglers as sajid javid was
just saying to you by working together
to have coastal protect patrols and
other measures it's also that we haven't
been able to work together to tackle the
things that are driving the movement of
people the asylum system across europe
and across the world has completely
broken down if you look at the countries
that people are fleeing from it's syria
it's afghanistan there are reasons why
people are on the move and the world has
been completely unable to come together
to deal with that the government is
writing open letters to the french that
they're releasing via social media
calling on the french to do things that
any responsible government would have
already done to get in place a mechanism
across europe to be able to return
people to safe third countries they
travel through to agree safe and legal
routes for people who we owe obligations
to to come here and sajid javid just
told you trevor that the government is
legislating to make that happen you
can't legislate
just to criminalize organizations like
the rnli who go out to try and help
people in the channel and think that
will solve the problem one of the people
on the boat that sank um
just a week ago was an afghan soldier
who said he'd given up hope of being
able to get to britain through a legal
route because although
the home secretary announced an
expansion of that afghan refugee
settlement scheme that scheme hasn't
even opened yet and that was three
months ago these these routes simply
don't exist and they won't exist for as
long as the government continues to
engage in a blame game with others and
doesn't do the hard yards of sitting
down round the table and agreeing how
we're going to tackle this together
let's talk about what um if you were
sitting down with the french what you
would actually be saying to them um can
i first understand what is labour's
priority here um and i'm talking about
about in general i'm talking about what
you would do this week is it
to make sure that nobody drowns which
would mean for example taking people
on board
british coast guard or navy ships
irrespective
of whether they had a genuine claim or
not or is it
making sure that we get uh the numbers
who are landing down which would imply
that what you want to do above all is
turn those boats back what what is
labour's actual priority what were the
instructions that your government would
give to the border force
well of course we want to stop people
drowning off our coastline it's simply
unconscionable that we've got this
happening and involving children as well
and people who we owe obligations to but
the way that you do that is twofold
firstly you don't criminalize those like
the rnli who are trying to assist them
or put wave machines in the channel as
pretty patel has suggested to simply
smash those boats out of the water you
do that by trying to disrupt a system
that is thriving on people's despair and
on criminality so we should be working
with the french to arrest those people
smugglers who are who are fueling this
and are providing unsafe passage for
people they're profiting from human
misery so we need joint french british
action to do that we should be
intercepting these boats we should be
arresting the people smugglers and we
should be stopping people from drowning
but then we ought to be working together
in order to deal with the with with the
bigger issue and let me just give you an
example i met with the pakistani
government at the height of the afghan
refugee crisis there are 1.4 million
afghan refugees in camps in pakistan
alone some of those are people to whom
britain owes obligations but there is no
route to get here at all at the moment
others are people that france could
potentially assist canada australia the
united states and other countries
besides but until we have a global
asylum system that is capable of
responding to that and sharing the the
strain of this together we are going to
see desperate people making desperate
crossings and we've got to deal with it
i get that but with respect
this is a real issue
for every single day from now
somebody who is running one of these
smuggling rings watching this interview
now will have taken from what you said
just now
that
if he is prepared to play chicken with
these people's lives a labor
administration would simply
say okay
we'll let this this one in
aren't you actually simply encouraging
the people smugglers to believe
that in the end
if they are prepared to put people in
these small boats
we will they will get across
well firstly let me speak directly to
your hypothetical people smuggler under
a labour government if you were to
continue with this reckless disregard
for human life we will work with
international partners to find you to
intercept you and to lock you up for a
very long time this is profiting from
human misery and it simply won't stand
we would open up safe and legal routes
with our international partners and urge
other countries to do the same to pull
the rug out from under the business
model that these smugglers
currently rely on of desperate desperate
people who have no other options and we
would work with our international
partners to tackle the underlying
drivers of conflict and insecurity
including climate change which is
forcing many
many people 26 million people to move
across the world unless and until we
have a government that is capable of
responding to the scale of the challenge
the only people
that benefit are the people smugglers
and the rest of us all lose
lisa andy thank you very much indeed for
your time